first impressions of the all-new Samsung
Galaxy s23 lineup the ultra the plus and
the s23 what are these phones like let's
break it down for you real quick here
they are this is an evolution not a
revolution if you already have an s22
ultra an s22 Plus or s22 you may say to
yourself you know what do I need to
upgrade for this one and it depends on
your usage if you are a power user then
you're gonna enjoy the new Snapdragon
8th Gen 2 processor inside of it and the
200 megapixel camera in the ultra if
you're not a power user you're like look
the s22 ultra is so good I'm barely
using any of the features that are
inside of it then you know what you may
want to hold out this year but if you're
coming from an S21 or even an s20 or
even an older phone than that and you
love this Samsung ecosystem then you're
really going to enjoy the s23 lineup
especially the ultra the new 200
megapixel camera is really impressive
better and low light for photography and
videography than the s22 Ultras and we
also have that new Snapdragon 8th Gen 2
so the processing is even better the
performance the speed is really really
good now you're only going to notice
when you're using Pro applications and
really pushing the phone to its limits
especially in gaming but for day-to-day
usage it's very similar to last year's
performance which was already so good so
here's my take on this I love the phone
it's one of my favorite Android phones
of last year and this will probably be
one of my favorite Android phones of
2023 thus far so check out us having a
little fun with the s23 ultra what's up
guys we're here at the Samsung Galaxy
experience space 105 in the world here
in Singapore for the launch of the
all-new s23 Ultra and the s23 series of
course we've been testing this out here
in a variety of situations low light uh
portrait photography video stabilization
trying a lot of the new features of the
s23 ultra which essentially for a lot of
the note fans out there is the note on
steroids the Snapdragon 8th Gen 2
processor inside of the 6.8 inch AMOLED
display you've got a 200 megapixel
camera 12 10 10 on the back and a 12
megapixel camera on the front of this as
well you've got up to 8K 30 frames for
video recording and you also have pro
video mode on this which does carry over
from the s22 Ultra Series as well with
the 200 megapixel camera sensor is I
mean this is something relatively new to
smartphones out there and it's very
impressive especially in low light
situations where that's going to kick in
with the pixel bidding to give you
better low light performance for
photography and you can also see it in
video as well so we're going to run
through spaces here a little bit we're
going to try it against a 100 megapixel
medium format camera just for fun just
to see how good the resolution is out of
this camera system so Zaki let's go
inside and let's uh have some fun with
you doing some video I know Debbie you
didn't know this but now you're going on
a trip with Zaki the soul yeah right now
in about five four three two one welcome
to Seoul
do you think we have a budget to put you
on a plane come on
the Knights of Seoul we're in Korea
we were just in Singapore now we're in
Korea yeah you know the main the amazing
thing of YouTube we can just like that
go from one country to the next all
right what are we doing here in Korea
show you the power of Michael
okay
I do but it's on an s23 ultra because
you only you have one yeah
sure okay okay Zach you getting my go to
my good angle right okay
all right so I'll take one with the
testimony all right all right
on the spot Impressions uh definitely
there is more exposure in the s23 ultra
versus the iPhone 14 pro Max I would say
that there's a little bit more blooming
coming out of the ultra so that might be
an exposure setting you might have to
adjust I would probably want to drop the
exposure a little bit on the s23 ultra
just to sort of reduce that blooming
effect but if it's a camera for camera
right now versus the iPhone 14 pro Max
it's a tough comparison you guys decide
let us know in the comments which one
you prefer
foreign
epic Montage with Debbie Debbie you're
part of the Epic Montage the b-roll
do you know what that means
do you know what epic Montage means no
no you sure you want to be part of this
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
this is me going through lines yes
all right so here's the deal with a new
200 megapixel sensor in the s23 ultra I
decided to bring out the Hasselblad x2d
100 megapixel medium format now 100
megapixel versus 200 megapixel how good
is the s23 ultra of course the sensor
size is different we know that but just
for fun uh comparison how does it
compare
to 100 megapixels of medium format power
let's find out
Abby giving the good modeling pose for
Instagram
it's really weird Abby's Abby's turning
red one two
now we're gonna take the phone and do
the same thing yeah yeah that's it
that's it one two
so as we saw from the images there of
course the Hasselblad will win this
competition there was no comparison
anyway I mean you have a sensor like
this versus a sensor like this so it is
going to be a very different thing but
it was just fun to try out 200
megapixels of course with a Snapdragon
8th Gen 2 processor how fast it
processes a large image like that in a
smartphone a big step what we're seeing
out in the industry thus far 108 was
sort of the standard and now 200 is
I guess the new standard what's next who
knows meet the summit e16 flip featuring
the latest 11th gen Intel Core i7
processor RTX 30 series graphics and a
16 inch QHD plus touchscreen panel with
a 360 degree hinge better yet it lets
you unleash maximum productivity with up
to 11 hours of battery life at just 2
kilograms the summit e16 flip offers
unprecedented performance and
functionality allowing you to work and
play anywhere and anytime so as you guys
saw we had a lot of fun with the phone
brief Hands-On time but we are going to
be doing comparison videos so we're
looking at doing a gaming comparison
possibly against the Rog phone 6. so you
want to subscribe for that and also a
battle between the camera phones out
there the iPhone 14 pro Max versus the
s23 ultra and possibly something from
xiaomi we're not too sure yet we'll see
what we can get our hands on but that
will be a battle royale that you do not
want to miss so if you like those kind
of videos subscribe to the channel
because a lot more of those are coming
your way with that guys take care stay
safe and check out more of our reviews
right here